[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros aquí en france 24 si revelan
con gusto saludarlos en esta oportunidad
vamos hasta brasil específicamente a la
ciudad de río de janeiro con nuestra
corresponsal
valeria saccone autora del reportaje que
veremos a continuación
valeria le pregunto cómo ha mejorado la
situación de los migrantes venezolanos
cientos de miles de migrantes que han
huido de su país a brasil en la
operación acogida por la onu
yo diría que ha mejorado bastante la
situación está bajo control tras un
comienzo un poco difícil al principio ni
nadie esperaba esta avalancha de
migrantes y cuando estuvimos allí hace
dos años había muchos venezolanos
acampados en las calles de boavista la
capital del estado norteño de roraima y
en pacaraima que era la última ciudad de
brasil antes de la frontera incluso hubo
un brote xenófobo cuando un grupo de
brasileños quemó un campamento de
venezolanos desde entonces el ejército
brasileño junto con la acnur ha
vertebrado una serie de abrigos son en
este momento once invo avista y uno
funcionando en pacaraima ya no se ven
personas acampando y además el cierre de
la frontera ha ayudado a reducir
bastante el número de venezolanos que
están siendo enviados a otras regiones
de brasil donde pueden encontrar trabajo
a través de un programa pionero llamado
de interiorización y es lo que
precisamente contamos en el reportaje
así es valeria le pidió entonces que se
quede con nosotros para ver
que usted realizó con carlos favale el
rule veamos este reporteros
[Música]
desde 2018 brasil enfrenta la mayor
emergencia humanitaria del siglo tras la
llegada de unos 650.000 migrantes desde
venezuela
[Música]
en los últimos dos años brasil se
convirtió en el país de américa latina
que más concede el estatus de refugiado
a los venezolanos en total más de 46 mil
refugiados fueron regularizados este
dato contrasta con las cifras de
colombia y perú los dos países de la
región que reciben más migrantes desde
venezuela
va a firmar una autorización una
autorización para nosotros apreciamos
podría tomarle fotografías el ejército
brasileño coordina la operación acogida
un programa que ampara de forma temporal
a los refugiados en los 11 abrigos de
boavista la capital de roraima el estado
norteño que hace frontera con venezuela
aquí tenemos la sala de la cola roja
ofrece servicio de contacto telefónico
para ayudar a los venezolanos a hacer
contacto con su familia este es el
corazón de la operación acogida es aquí
donde los venezolanos pueden resolver
cualquier tipo de trámite como pedir la
residencia o el estatus de refugiado
cada día unas 70 personas son vacunadas
gratuitamente contra el sarampión la
gripe y la fiebre amarilla
colocan o jugaban una panela pequeña con
medio determinado
aquí los refugiados también reciben
clases de portugués antes de ser
enviados a otra ciudad
gregorio que sigo desde su nacimiento
está a punto de mudarse a sao paulo
donde espera comenzar una nueva vida y
continuar con la gestión que venía
realizando en venezuela'
es la formación y capacitación de las
personas con deficiencia visual
la interiorización es el punto fuerte de
la operación acogida esta estrategia
consiste en trasladar a los refugiados
inmigrantes venezolanos a regiones donde
hay más oportunidades de empleo
él está esperando aquí para un puesto de
trabajo como camionero entonces él
necesita un carnet de conducir de aquí
de brasil
este modelo ha sido elogiado en varias
ocasiones por las naciones unidas y
agitado el colapso económico y social de
roraima que es uno de los estados más
pobres de brasil
desde el inicio de la operación ya
interiorizamos desde aquí desde el
roraima hacia el interior de brasil a 42
mil 496 venezolanos antes de la pandemia
la media era de 3.000 refugiados por mes
algunos incluso consiguen un contrato de
trabajo antes de su traslado y nosotros
hacemos el contacto con la empresa esta
empresa contrata al venezolano en alguna
ciudad del interior de brasil y nosotros
hacemos el transporte logístico también
hacemos el acompañamiento a lo largo de
tres meses para comprobar si la
interiorización funciona
esta escena se repite cada semana
decenas de venezolanos viajan en autobús
hasta manaos donde subirán un avión para
alcanzar su destino final los billetes
son costeados por el gobierno brasileño
y las agencias internacionales que
operan en esta región fronteriza
jose david
este hombre trabajó durante 24 años en
la principal petrolera de venezuela en
roraima hizo un curso para aprender a
manejar tractores ahora se está mudando
al estado de goiás donde le espera un
empleo quiero seguir adelante me siento
joven me siento fuerte tengo mucho
conocimiento de mi cabeza que quiero
explotar y no y no ha podido gracias a
brasil por esta oportunidad que me está
dando
como omar son miles los refugiados que
ya fueron reubicados gracias a ese
sistema el número de refugiados en los
campos de boavista pasó de 12 mil a
4.500 en pocos meses el cierre de la
frontera por causa de la pandemia ha
sido otro elemento determinante para
alcanzar este resultado
el coronavirus complicó aún más la
situación de los refugiados y causó una
crisis dentro de la crisis a pesar de
todas las restricciones el programa de
interiorización no se detuvo
la pandemia obligó a la agencia de la
onu para los refugiados el acnur a
reorganizar los campos de refugiados fue
necesario aumentar la distancia social
para minimizar el riesgo de contagio el
resultado ha sido alentador hubo menos
de 10 muertes por kobe entre los 12.000
venezolanos que estaban en boavista al
principio de la emergencia sanitaria
nunca se puede hablar de éxito cuando
tenemos víctimas mortales pero sí es
verdad que las estimaciones
epidemiológicas que teníamos a
principios de marzo eran mucho peores de
la realidad actual
[Aplausos]
acnur también participó en la creación
de ese hospital de campaña que ya
atendió a más de 4.500 pacientes tanto
venezolanos como brasileños mil
profesionales sanitarios trabajaron a
rajatabla para que 1.100 personas
pudiesen salir de aquí por su propio pie
hoy el porcentaje de venezolanos
contagiados corresponde a menos del 2
por ciento de la población porque el
trabajo que fue hecho en los abrigos la
prevención con mascarillas todo el
protocolo ayudó a prevenir el contagio
en todos los abrigos o abrigos
bajo el mando de los militares la
operación acogida ofrece una respuesta
coordinada a la emergencia migratoria 11
ministerios están involucrados además de
un centenar de agencias gubernamentales
y no gubernamentales
el reto es prepararse para hacer frente
al nuevo flujo de refugiados que se
espera que llegue cuando reabra una
frontera el otro desafío es mantener
viva esta operación a pesar de la crisis
económica de brasil y de los recortes
causados por la pandemia o hacemos un
esfuerzo con todas las dificultades
aunque no tengamos los recursos
adecuados vamos está o estaremos
promoviendo un caos futuro para las
próximas generaciones y brazos
porque la migración es un desafío muy
grande un desafío muy integral
el talón de aquiles de la operación
acogida son los campamentos
autogestionados este se llama caoba no
co que en la lengua de los indígenas
warao significa nuestro dormitorio
aquí viven cerca de 900 personas unos
400 son indígenas de cuatro etnias
distintas y el resto venezolanos
criollos
fuente es el espacio donde yo vivo no
está muy limpio real y pertenece a la
etnia warao en venezuela- estudio
turismo y comunicación hoy actúa como
líder en este asentamiento bueno tengo
una cocinita también que tenemos un
poquito más de comodidad de cocinar aquí
dentro de este mismo espacio
como lean y muchos migrantes prefieren
vivir en este campamento donde hay más
sombras y menos calor que los abrigos
oficiales y desde luego menos reglas
sino porque aquí igual tenemos la
libertad de salir a la hora que nosotros
queramos porque muchas familias que
viven aquí sobreviven por la recolección
de lata de hierro y pueden salir pueden
salir de este lugar a la hora que ellos
quieran llegar también a la hora que
ellos quieran dentro de un abrigo no
vamos a tener esa libertad que tenemos
acá es la de tener suficiente agua
cada semana cáritas distribuye alimentos
para que los indígenas puedan cocinar
sus especialidades
aquí hay fruta papa zanahoria y cebolla
estas son las verduras necesarias para
hacer la sopa pero este pequeño lujo
tiene los días contados en diciembre
este asentamiento va a ser desalojado
los mandos militares quieren que todos
los residentes se instalen en los
abrigos de la operación acogida esta
solución no agrada a los venezolanos
que nosotros queremos un lugar como este
lugar que queda aire que todos nos
divertimos una visita no llega a visitas
nosotros recibimos y yo vi cómo se vive
un abrigo parece una cárcel entonces
nosotros no estamos acostumbrados y
nosotros somos indígenas pero sabemos lo
en qué lugar vivimos cómo vivimos la
condición limpias
una alternativa es adaptar los abrigos a
las costumbres de los indígenas es lo
que han hecho en la ciudad fronteriza de
pacaraima este centro que acoge a 380
personas se llama la localidad en la
lengua guaraní significa hogar de karina
inekaren teolinda lleva aquí tres años
es cantante y artesana aquí las hamacas
reemplazaron los colchones teolinda no
quiere regresar a venezuela mientras la
situación económica no mejore
no hay alimentos no hay medicinas y
muchas personas se movieron en que sus
cosas de enfermedad por falta de
medicina toda la comunidad que yo lo que
estaba viviendo en un municipio antonio
díaz adictos de dinero porque se
murieron muchos niños de sarampión y
personas mayores de la enfermedad cólera
fallecieron
la ley brasileña no permite la
interiorización después los nómadas e
indígenas los warao están literalmente
varados en pacaraima como las canoas que
dejaron atrás en sus aldeas llenas de
manglares la perspectiva de los
indígenas es que la frontera reabra y
que ellos puedan circular libremente
como hacían antiguamente ellos esperan
que la situación en venezuela mejore y
que puedan volver a vivir donde vivían
en principio ellos no quieren
establecerse aquí en el país
[Música]
a la espera de que la frontera reabra
los indígenas warao pueden contar con el
soporte de padre jesus un cura español
que lleva más de una década en pacaraima
pólvora hoy ha sufrido mucho en este
éxodo verde tal vez hasta aquí
pero vienes siempre lleno de sueños
siempre lleno de esperanza desde el
inicio de la crisis migratoria padre
jesus ha sido el ángel de la guarda de
los refugiados especialmente de los
indígenas creó un comedor social que
aplacaba el hambre de 1500 personas por
día tuvo que parar por causa de la
pandemia pero ahora distribuye cestas de
alimentos están aquí por absoluta
necesidad para no morir de hambre ya
usted a un indígena awá le dice no ir a
san pablo y dan mato grosso del sur y
tiene miedo él quiere volver a su mundo
a su mundo de las aguas a ese mundo de
las canoas a su cultura a su espíritu
que es totalmente diferente a este
este cura teme la reapertura de la
frontera desconfía que se produzca un
colapso humanitario peor que hace unos
años cuando un grupo de habitantes de
pacaraima ki-moon campamentos de
refugiados para protestar contra lo que
tildaron de innovación quemó la ropa lo
venezolano en conjunto con su gente
comerciante quemando la ropa de la
venezolana en septiembre poco antes de
las elecciones en los eeuu
el secretario de estado mark pope o
realiza una visita a los campos de
refugiados de boavista para la oposición
se trató de una afrenta a la autonomía
diplomática de brasil y a la soberanía
nacional el ministro de exteriores tuvo
que comparecer en el senado para dar
explicaciones porque es importante
recordar que los eeuu son el mayor
financiador del mundo de las operaciones
de la agencia de la onu para los
refugiados y de la organización
internacional de migración y
específicamente específicamente que el
gobierno norteamericano de sino más
64 millones de dólares a la financiación
de actividades y el apoyo a migrantes y
refugiados venezolanos demostración para
el excanciller de la era lula el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro ha empañado
la imagen de brasil con una política
exterior agresiva que se aleja de los
principios tradicionales de la no
intervención en los asuntos de los otros
países venezuela está cercada por todos
los lados y pompeo vino aquí es una cosa
triste y vergonzosa porque es como si él
hubiese venido a inspeccionar un campo
de batalla es una agresión a la
soberanía brasileña con la connivencia
del gobierno brasileño los refugiados
son la cara más visible del fracaso
diplomático de la comunidad
internacional frente a la crisis
venezolana con la elección de joe biden
es de esperar que la relación entre
brasil y los estados unidos empeore lo
que está por ver si el nuevo presidente
mantendrá el apoyo financiero a la
operación acogida
y seguimos conversando con nuestra
corresponsal valeria saccone autora de
este reportaje que acabamos de ver
valeria el ejército brasileño tiene como
lema brazo fuerte mano amiga esta
económica se está realmente extendiendo
hacia los refugiados venezolanos
es lo que hemos podido comprobar allí
hay que recordar que desde el fin de la
dictadura militar en 1985 el ejército
brasileño ha participado en cada vez más
operaciones humanitarias por ejemplo en
haití y el líbano en ese estado de
roraima hemos visto a militares
comprometidos con su trabajo
involucrados más allá de los meramente
profesionales sin ir más lejos uno de
nuestros protagonistas omar patiño que
le grabamos cuando se estaba yendo al
estado de goiás dentro del programa de
interior interiorización hablé con él
hace un par de semanas y me contó que el
coronel brandáo le estaba ayudando a
reunificarse con su mujer que se había
quedado atrás en pacaraima lo que
demuestra que de alguna forma el
ejército si hace un seguimiento de esos
migrantes también es verdad que también
hay críticas por ejemplo algunos
migrantes se quejaban de que hay una
alta rotación de los mandos militares y
que no siempre los militares nuevos que
llegan están en la misma línea de
colaborar pero en la general manuel de
barros nos contaba que de aquí a un año
probablemente 90% de los militares
saldrán
a civiles trabajando en los campos de
acogida así es valeria gracias entonces
por este reportaje y también gracias a
ustedes por si para acompañarnos aquí en
france 24
[Música]